Comment descendre sous l'eau sans se mouiller ?
Généralement, lorsque nous prenons un bain, nous
sommes mouillés ! Mais peut-être que tu le savais
déjà ! Avec l'expérience d'aujourd'hui nous allons
voir qu'il est possible de descendre sous l'eau
sans être mouillé. Pour cela je vais avoir besoin
d'un grand vase à moitié rempli d'eau, de papier
absorbant, d'une bouteille évidée comme ceci,
avec son bouchon et une balle de ping-pong.
L'expérience est assez simple: on va prendre notre
récipient et on va mettre du papier absorbant dans
la bouteille comme ceci et on va venir plonger la
bouteille dans l'eau. La question maintenant :
est-ce que le mouchoir est sec ou est-ce qu'il
est mouillé ? Et bien si on le retire et qu'on
le reprend on voit qu'il est parfaitement sec,
il n'a pas été mouillé. Qu'est ce qui s'est passé?
Quand on voit une bouteille vidée de son eau,
on a tendance à penser qu'elle est vide
sauf qu'en réalité elle est pleine d'air.
Lorsque tu plonges la bouteille de cette manière,
l'eau pousse l'air mais l'air résiste. Tu peux
voir le niveau de l'eau monter. Résultat :
l'eau ne rentre pas dans la bouteille,
le papier reste sec. Ce système est connudepuis assez longtemps puisque les plongeurs
l'utilisaient avant l'invention des scaphandres
pour descendre dans les profondeurs marines, aller
travailler ou explorer. Aujourd'hui on utilise
ni scaphandre ni cloche comme ceux-ci mais on va
préférer l'utilisation de sous marins comme le
Nautile de l'Ifremer. Maintenant, je te propose
d'aller un peu plus loin avec cette expérience. On
va toujours utiliser notre vase, notre bouteille
mais cette fois une balle de ping-pong. On met
la balle de ping-pong dans l'eau et on remet la
bouteille comme ceci. Encore une fois l'eau n'est
pas rentrée dans la bouteille parce que la balle
de ping-pong y est au fond. Mais si on retire
le bouchon, l'eau va pousser l'air hors de la
bouteille elle peut sortir on voit d'ailleurs la
balle de ping-pong qui remonte. On a maintenant
la bouteille pleine d'eau, d'air et de balle de
ping-pong ! Si on rebouche la bouteille, l'eau
ne peut ni sortir ni rentrer dans la bouteille.
Ce qui fait que quand on tire la bouteille comme
ceci, l'eau reste dedans. On le voit avec la
balle de ping-pong qui flotte. Si on retire
complètement, l'eau retombe. Je t'invite à refaire
l'expérience chez toi ! Merci d'avoir regardé cet
épisode et je te donne rendez-vous la semaine
prochaine pour répondre à une nouvelle question.